nos piden evaluar la expresión 5 a la
potencia x menos 3 a la potencia x para
x igualados pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo cuál es el resultado de
esta expresión cuando x es igual a todos
muy bien vamos a resolverlo juntos lo
que tenemos que hacer es que cada vez
que veamos una x la reemplazamos con un
2 entonces esta expresión para x igual a
2 sería 5 a la segunda potencia menos 3
a la segunda potencia bueno cuál va a
ser el resultado 5 a la segunda potencia
es lo mismo que 5 por 5 y luego tenemos
que restar 3 por 3 3 por 3 ahora por el
orden de las operaciones tenemos que
hacer las multiplicaciones primero o
resolver los exponentes que son estas
multiplicaciones y para que sea más
claro voy a poner unos paréntesis aquí
esto es igual a 5 por 5 es 25 menos 9 es
igual a 16 este es el resultado de esta
expresión para x igual a 2
hagamos otro ejemplo ahora nos preguntan
cuál es el valor de y al cuadrado menos
x a la cuarta potencia cuando ya es
igual a 9 y x es igual a 2 una vez más
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
en este caso tenemos variables como las
bases en lugar de que sean los
exponentes y tenemos dos variables
diferentes pero lo que tenemos que hacer
es que cuando veamos una y la
sustituimos por un 9 y cuando veamos una
x la sustituimos por un 2
así que ya al cuadrado es igual a 9 al
cuadrado menos x que es igual a 2 a la
cuarta potencia cuál es el resultado de
esto bueno 9 al cuadrado es igual a 9
por 9 todo esto que tenemos aquí es 81 9
por 9 a eso le vamos a restar 2 a la
cuarta potencia cuánto es 2 a la cuarta
potencia 2 por 2 por 2 por 2 2 por 2 es
igual a 4 4 por 2 es igual a 8 y 8 por 2
es igual a 16 de manera que tenemos 81
16 ahora cuál es el resultado de esto 81
6 es igual a 75 y luego le restamos
otros 10 esto es igual a 65
este es el resultado que al cuadrado
menos x en la cuarta potencia cuando es
igual a 9 y x es igual a 2 es igual a 65
y terminamos